l'image du petit corps inanimés des lan
curdy trois ans réfugiés syriens fuyant
la guerre échoué sur une place turc a
secoué la planète entière
une fois le premier choc passé
c'est vers le canada que les yeux du
monde se sont tournés
parce que le canada c'est là où sa
petite famille décimée pendant sa fuite
voulait venir
il y avait de la parenté mais les portes
du canada ne se sont pas ouvertes
suffisamment vite ni pour eux ni pour
des milliers d'autres
quel contraste avec la crise des boat
people asiatique à la fin des années 70
soixante mille d'entre eux ont été
accueillis en deux ans athènes mais
c'était une autre époque
je pense qu'on a gardé au canada une
espèce de mythologie de stéréotypes de
ce qu'on est
on pense encore qu'on est par exemple
impliqué dans les opérations de maintien
de la paix et qu'on est une terre
d'accueil pour tous les miséreux de la
caf
c'est pas vrai on est plus il faudrait
leur devenir louise arbour ancien haut
commissaire de l'onu pour les droits de
l'homme n'est pas la seule à s'inquiéter
par exemple les opérations de maintien
de la paix les vrais les traditionnels
nous n'y sommes pratiquement plus
présent je crois qu'on pourrait remplir
admis autobus avec les canadiens qui
sont dans le monde
ex ambassadeur du canada en egypte au
pakistan et en indonésie série de
kerchove a aussi piloté en 2010 la
candidature canadienne au conseil de
sécurité de l'onu qui s'est terminée par
un échec
quelle ironie le canada forcé de laisser
la place aux petits portugal son
influence n'est plus qu'un lointain
souvenir
après le coup d'état contre gorbatchev
george bush le père appelle brahim au
long des dix ans bryan il faut
absolument que tu viennes qu'on discute
de ça et voir qu'on peut faire ça c'est
de l' influence madame et ils ont
concocté l'expédition de mitterrand et
de cole parlent en allant russie
littéralement sorti un gorbatchev de là
à l'époque grandiose où le canada était
un joueur de premier plan sur la scène
mondiale le canada de johnson ferait
rédacteurs de la déclaration universelle
des droits de l'homme de lester b
pearson notre seul prix nobel de la paix
et perd des casques bleus la force de
maintien de la paix de l'onu
le canada de brian mulroney assumant le
leadership de la lutte contre
l'apartheid pas d'autre solution que de
rendre complètement nos relations avec
l'affectation l'amitié toute irlandaise
entre brian mulroney et ronald reagan a
certainement joué mais les deux
présidents suivants ont aussi placé le
canada au centre de leurs stratégies
internationales notamment face à
l'ennemi numéro 1 l'ours soviétiques et
russes
l'accord du libre-échange la convention
sur les mines antipersonnel pilotée par
jean chrétien sont autant d'exemples du
leadership canadien d'autrefois
mais les temps changent
selon ce professeur de l'alberta fin
connaisseur de la pensée conservatrice
le canada a amorcé un virage il y a déjà
deux décennies le canada dans les
milieux des années 90 à transférer
complètement ses allégeances de l'onu à
l'otan et ça c'est fait souvent non
chrétiens ça s'est fait vraiment chez
les libéraux et les conservateurs ont
maintenu et conserver ce genre d'
alléger d'autant plus dit-il que cela
correspond à leur vision de l'histoire
du canada le canada quand même un passé
militaire impasse et britanniques et les
conservateurs mettre l'accent sur ces
moments-là de l'histoire militaire
canadienne au lieu de au lieu de mettre
l'accent sur le maintien de la paix
la fin de la guerre froide et de
l'ancien ordre mondial bipolaire change
aussi la donne
nouveaux ennemis nouvelle stratégie
militaire
mais globalement que disent les chiffres
où est l'argent les défenses canadiennes
à l'étranger par rapport au produit
intérieur brut ont été divisés par deux
au cours des vingt dernières années y
compris les dépenses militaires
alors qu'en 1990 au sein du g7
le canada était au même niveau que
l'allemagne l'italie et bien au dessus
du japon
il est aujourd'hui le dernier même
constat si on se compare aux autres
puissances moyennes la norvège
l'australie la suède le canada est en
queue de peloton la perception du canada
à l'étranger s'est beaucoup détériorée
dans les dernières années dans la
dernière décennie pour plusieurs raisons
notamment le virage commercial joue un
rôle très important
selon ce spécialiste ce qui a été encore
plus dommageable pour l'image du canada
c'est l'orientation idéologique de son
aide internationale depuis une dizaine
d'années les organismes religieux à
majorité chrétien en eau bénéficier de
façon disproportionnée aussi les
autorités canadiennes se sont servis de
l'aide pour prendre parti dans les
conflits
le veut avec le positionnement du canada
n'en conflit israélo-palestinien alors
qu'on devrait avoir une grille
humanitaire et d'aidé
peu importe de leur nationalité les
palestiniens ou la commune
d'israël lorsque l'on constate c'est que
notamment on a retiré une bonne partie
des financements humanitaire aux
palestiniens et inversement
on concentre nos efforts à travers
israël pour le gouvernement de stephen
harper la politique étrangère doit
servir à défendre des principes selon
ses détracteurs il fait preuve de
dogmatisme beaucoup insistent le canada
est aujourd'hui de plus en plus isolé
nous c'est la politique on fout quand
les rend fous les iraniens dehors on ne
parle plus à la réussir alors si vous
avez plus personne à qui parler vous
n'allez pas parler à qui que ce soit
bien que fidèle à ses alliances
militaires le canada fait souvent
cavalier seul avec ses positions
tranchées
ottawa ne s'est pas fait beaucoup d'amis
les américains peuvent prendre des
positions ils sont complètement isolés
les chinois aussi on s'y attendait
grandes puissances mais des puissances
moyennes comme le canada
la seule façon d'avoir un état c'est de
se créer des alliances des consensus
d'être très présent il faut être un
joueur alors allé s'asseoir sur le banc
de la patinoire vie de balle je ne plus
commencer un jeu sur ce fut mon jeu
c'est le seul jeu qu'il la veut rester
sur le bord de la patinoire mais ne pas
se passer grand chose